well let me um let me do a strange thing
let me steal man perhaps the most
outrageous point that Robyn D'Angelo
makes in her book the one that we are
all being being exposed to too much and
this is that all white people are racist
we've all heard this now and I don't
know for sure that it originates with
her but but her book is currently the
one that is spreading most widely and
you know we've talked about it before on
this show so the point is absurd on its
face for sure all white people are
racist really but the trick here is that
she has redefined what racist means and
so that's illegitimate and I think we've
mentioned before that merriam-webster's
is the dictionaries now falling in line
with this redefinition of racism and you
know that's a kind of double speak
that's you know the the second form of
new language that Orwell writes about
not new speak but double speak turning
turning extant terms into something that
means something so different that when
people use them no one is quite sure
which meaning they intend to be using so
if we sidestep sidestep that linguistic
trap though that she's laid for us and
say well certainly I know I'm not racist
what the hell is she talking about what
what she means and I really don't know
that she has anything good faith about
her at all
but what she and the movement means when
they are talking truth is that it's true
that people with white skin do continue
to benefit from the privileges
especially historic but also still
contemporary that having white skin
converse that's just that has been true
and that's true even though class and
geography are often better predictors of
of outcomes than is skin color so now we
can all imagine say a poor white girl in
Alabama in rural Alabama versus a
middle-class black girl in Chicago and
ask you know who is more likely to
succeed in this world and it's going to
be the the black child in this case
even though it is also true that when
those two people are making decisions
about where to drive at what time of
night and what stores to go into and and
what their reaction is if they're
driving and they see police is going to
be different by race so all of those
things can be true and you know it's
it's insane objectionable reprehensible
all of this to call that thing racism
that that is that is that is actually
deplorable right yeah um I'd like to
take that word back too but it it does
obscure bizarrely right it obscures this
kernel of truth at the bottom and now
you have people pushing back so hard
against this insane nonsense that they
are also pushing back against the thing
that is true and that's that is going to
be where the divide actually sticks I
think oh it's going to well you know I
put out a video I can't remember exactly
when but I it's called
speak of the devil and the idea was that
they are gonna call forth exactly the
racist beast that they are claiming
dominates the landscape right now by
forcing white people by backing them
into the wall together you're gonna
force them to see things in racial terms
and it's not a surprise what's coming
it's perfectly predictable and it's
extremely dangerous yeah so anyway good
job steel Manning obviously the problem
with the analysis is that we are forced
to the last step it's not the things are
racially well distributed it's not that
they have ever gotten to zero right
we never neutralize the effects of
slavery and Jim Crow and so we don't
even know what the experiment would do I
have a pretty good guess but we don't
know what the experiment would do if you
ever got everybody to the starting line
at the same time and I think it would be
quite equal but what we are told is that
the very fact of disadvantage that shows
up in outcomes is evidence of racism
which is a cognitive process occurring
inside of the minds of white people we
are also told not only is it there and
in need of immediate challenge but it is
incurable
yeah those two things don't go together
yeah no there's
there's there's a bait-and-switch
constantly and you know we can look at
this this book that's insane
white fragility book and we can it's
harder to pinpoint the claims of
activists because they'll always say I
didn't mean it then it was you know it's
not what it seems
but the talking about the population
level the systemic the actual systemic
truth of systems that have benefited
people with white skin conflating that
with individual level racism is
something that the movement claims to
understand the distinction between but
is very very happy to do a constant
bait-and-switch between and of course
this this final point that you make the
the idea that not only are you born
racist but if you claim you're not
you're proving that you're racist and if
it come you are well then you're
obviously racist it's it's I think the
central rhetorical trap of a rhetorical
Kafka trap of the entire book and the
entire movement that any defense of
yourself is taken as evidence that you
are in fact guilty of the thing of which
you are accused yeah there's no escape
and therefore what is the conclusion of
that the conclusion is you have to do
what we say anybody who understood that
you are guilty of racism inherently
because the color of your skin and who
doesn't like that because who likes
racism anybody who agrees with those
things the next question is okay well
then you're an ally aren't you oh yeah I
guess I'm an ally
oh well then if you're an ally what does
that mean it means you have to do what
we say which means you have to take the
risk on our behalf which means you have
to go and punish other people and so it
is a contagious ideology oh it's and
it's it's effective what parts of Rahm
DeAngelo's book do you agree with there
are parts I agree with how do you hold a
dominant culture accountable without
slipping into tearing all the white
Jesus statues down as a sign of white
supremacy so I I really I I did my best
to steal man maybe the most egregious
point in it by saying well if you if you
go back if you replace the word racist
with benefiting from structures that
have in the past been racist policies
then yes people with white skin are in
fact still benefiting from those
stretchers today I maybe will say more
about this depending on whether or not
let's say that may come out soon and if
not I'll share more of this hum with the
eyes
later I would say two things there are
parts of her book that I agree with the
ISB and number there's a price marker on
it I believe that that is the price I
don't believe it's worth it but I do
believe you think they're factually
accurate factually that's hard I agree
with you mean you think that this is
actually a description of reality to the
extent that there is a factual
description of the selling price I agree
that it is the selling price but my
point would be why the hell are we in a
situation where we're answering the
question which parts of this incredibly
insane book do we believe in is that a
game now I mean which parts of mine comp
do we believe what I mean no the book is
so bad that searching for the good in it
is an insane exercise search for a book
that is at least somewhat good before
you try to find the parts because many
people you and I are lucky now not three
years ago but that Whedon we presumably
never have to face one of these things
again one of these trainings went you
know a colleague coming up to you with
sad eyes and saying can you just read
the book yet then you'll understand just
own your white supremacy right like a
lot of people are still having to do
this and so being armed with okay
here's a point that makes sense and you
know and now that you've know that I've
demonstrated my attempt at good faith
and understanding what is in this thing
let me explain to you why overall it is
divisive demonic destabilizing of good
political structure and all the rest i I
disagree with this that book is a Trojan
horse and the idea that we are in some
way required to spend our effort finding
what might be acceptable in it is
preposterous this is a bad person who's
written a dangerous book and the fact is
there's a limited amount of time in a
life if you're going to dedicate it to
books find one that actually helps you
this one to read it to find the good in
it you are likely to absorb garbage
arguments so my point with you okay so
I'm just like I just read it as you know
I know I had looked at parts of it when
it came out but I actually because I was
asked to write this piece I actually
finally just sat down I read the damn
thing which drove me a bit mad
but I did so over the last couple of
days and yeah I wasn't reading it to
find the good but I was reading it to
figure out you know what what what is
there and what are the kernels of truth
in this that is being used brandished as
this as this marker of fealty in this
movement is true that you can point to
and say yes that thing is true that is
real grievance that thing is true
but this approach is nasty and
reprehensible well but you also pointed
out what I think neither of us knew
there's a piece of tape of Robyn
D'Angelo speaking at Evergreen that
Benjamin voice has shown and I believe
Mike Nanna and his documentary also
shows it you know she just shoutout to
Benjamin boy so I went to Benjamin when
I told him I've been asked to write this
piece and said I know you've talked
about Robyn DeAngelo's appearance on
campus on evergreen campus can you point
me he's done in a number of places and
he also directed me to the actually full
video and man is that one when a piece
of work yeah so she was she was there in
spring of 2016 while we were actually in
Ecuador it was just it was the same
month as the boat accident that I almost
died in in Galapagos and we see many of
the usual suspects on campus speaking
they're willfully ridiculous truths yeah
and we see her actively dividing people
and in her language some of the stuff
that's not even in the book which wasn't
out yet like the book came out in 2018
but she was already doing her damage all
over the place
we see here in what she says even some
of the turns of phrase we then saw from
our own colleagues just months later
that then took an entire college down
right so then she's incredibly powerful
this is my point yeah um that was a talk
yeah now had I been at Evergreen when
she was there I would have gone to that
talk and I would have asked pointed
questions and I'm you know convinced
that I understand my own mind well
enough that I would not have been
persuaded by her nonsense but it's
obviously lethal to people who don't
have the proper tools to figure out how
to escape the logical traps right I'm
just saying if you're not expecting
these traps they'll catch you off guard
and you'll sign up for things
that seemed safe and they won't be so I
for the very same reason that I think it
is not safe to have her visit your
campus and lecture people on the racism
that they don't know is in their own
minds
it's not safe to assign people the job
of figuring out what good exists in her
book it's a garbage book
[Music]